that time of year again folks call the
duty season like me Hardy and Erin
Sampson here to tell us all about the
black ops 3 beta which we got a kind of
a like 24 hours early access on I know
48 maybe 48 Eric Tejano spent last night
basically leveling up to do on yeah all
night when he got to level 28 was it
yeah we're not sure if that's the cap
yet but that's like the soft cast his
cap yeah his goal was to unlock the
killer bee swarm okay you got that which
he did yeah yes killa beez well talk
about killer bees in just a second who
doesn't like talking about that first of
all Mike the specialist this is a sort
of a new aspect of the series and tell
us about the characters that you played
how you sort of how you unlock them and
how they work in the game sure yeah I
think this is one of the major additions
if not the major edition of black ops 3
so they're essentially these these
characters I mean they affect how you
look but that's minor but they also each
of them has these two abilities and one
is usually a weapon of some sort and the
second one's more of a tactical ability
kind of so you pick so piggy pick ruin
or a a lot of people have been using the
outrider because you start off with four
in the beta then you can unlock two more
at least but there's ruin their very
their superpowers are kind of like
destiny abilities though they have yet
ruined the first one you can use he has
this some like gravity spikes jumping
ground pound attack I smash Titan smash
life yeah there's the seraphs which you
is the fifth unlock in the beta and she
has like the hunters golden gun which is
just one hit kills that was good one of
my favorites it was like a revolver you
know that not the highest fire rate but
it was one hit kill so if you're
accurate enough and then you know the
outrider has the sparrow longbow which
is just explosive arrows but they also
have those secondary abilities which the
outrider has this division vision your
vision pulse and it just for like three
seconds will highlight through walls
anybody in the area which way they're
facing it's kind of like what the
spectator mode looks like if you're not
playing but probably the most
interesting ones so far those profits
glitch yeah that one's awesome and Rob
got really good at which you pop the
ability and it rewinds your last
full of moves okay so you can run into
we're still trying to like wrap her head
around this thing but like you could run
into a room drop a grenade and then
teleport backwards out of the room this
sounds like a lot like like I know it's
the same company now but racer from
overwatch yeah does the same thing we
were able to like backtrack the whole
way yeah so at one point when i was
using it i was up kind of this elevated
roof i sprinted down someone came around
a corner i used it and i ended up back
on the roof and then snipe them what
actually really happened is i missed and
someone else kill me but i like to
imagine I sniper but and then rob was
around any corner I was right behind him
when we were playing on the same team
someone was shooting at him he used it
to go back to where we were and I kind
of killed the person sorry so every once
in a while that creates some pretty
awesome like holy [ __ ] moments so it
worked really well but yeah the
specialist class in general these powers
you know they have like charge times and
there's certain perks that decrease
those charge times they really do affect
how you build your classes like what
weapons you use how you tailor it to
your play style so are you are you
always playing as a specialist it's not
basically you doing yes so you always
have at least one ability active you can
only be one specialist at a time and you
can only have one of their options
active sorry years they also talked
about how certain modes even limit the
number of certain specialist right yeah
the giraffe specialized draft will it be
yeah like so yeah people can as of now
you can have like four outriders in a
match to ruins right later on in the
certain competitive matches if you take
that ability no one else can use it okay
interesting dota style picking out your
loadout before before match it's it's
not in this but the stream that they did
had one more interesting mechanics I've
seen in a long time which is the band
protect system yeah where you can
actually vote in that to get rid of
something your opponent is using and
yeah check something that you're using
so like DotA's again kind of yeah yeah
the bonding system yeah that's weird and
it's what so when you're playing the
game do you at a distance know who your
fight like can you figure out who the
other specialists sister by looking at
them because presumably knowing what
they can do is keep killing them right
exactly yeah so I don't know if people
notice a few times during this game play
the gun will just start you'll start
glowing red and that means that the
outrider just used their vision pulse
ability right so they know exactly where
you are so whenever I saw that I was
like I'm either about to die but I'm
going to
try to make a break for it because they
are always going to have the upper hand
on me when you know when prophet uses
glitch and goes backwards I kind of look
for where they came from to expecting
them to come through the same doorway
twice in a row so it's definitely just
as useful to know how other people are
going to use it as well as how you're
going to offensively use it which is a
cool dynamic as far as you know like
considering other people's moves as
opposed to your own hmm so it's really
interesting as far as those go a lot of
comparisons obviously to games like
titanfall and to destiny as well last
year with advanced warfare we saw a game
that was very much like titanfall in
terms of movement and whatnot perhaps
maybe even sort of more futuristic and
more variable than time for Aaron head
is this one field does it feel more like
advanced warfare just feel more like a
black ops games normal the movement
system in this game is chasing after
titanfall more than advanced warfare
advanced warfare had I think what Chris
waters described as very staccato
movement yeah it's very jerky some some
people loved it some people hated it
this one it's got wall running it
doesn't do all running as well as
titanfall I'm always a big fan of if
you're gonna rip somebody off like do it
better than that you know like do it do
do something new or do something better
than the last guy in this case the wall
writing feels a little tact on there's
some very specific routes you can take
but they usually end in dead ends what
is this nonsense out that your health
storm right scorestreak yeah such as
hands out like but yeah he's praying or
something ought to do with my hands on
yeah you draw that arm laptops but yeah
I mean the wall running is it it's okay
it's the routes aren't as good as
titanfall titanfall you were learning as
long as you play titanfall you can learn
a new route yeah there was always a
route you didn't know this one a couple
rounds on a map you know the routes the
routes dead end and just drop you on to
the map at certain places one of the
things I real ex by tenant fall was the
sort of how long your lives were and how
well it wasn't just like a like you say
like it's short time to kill what what's
that this game feel like in comparison
to uh do you have longer lives are more
like Call of Duty the time to kill is
marginally longer so you're actually
having gunfights in this game which I
like advanced you know warfare feel like
you just come around
Corner your body would hit the ground
before you can even register you'd been
hit right and then you would respawn
before like you even knew what happened
so it's just this really weird like non
gunfight mechanic of whoever shot first
this one you do actually get into those
strafing gunfights and if you're both
while running you have that titanfall
moment we're both like trying to shooter
than when you makes a mistake and just
fall off the cliff yeah so there's
there's better moments in this one I
think because of the longer time to kill
yeah how long's the bitter running for
for people who preordered it it's
tomorrow Wednesday the 19th i think
until sunday the 23rd whatever sunday is
all weekend and you guys have been
playing obviously for sort of like a day
and some change iron first of all what's
what's your take on this this type of
game do did you play much advanced
warfare is this a type again it will
pull you back into call of duty or is it
not scratching message I think it's
doing more of what I'd like to see in
call of duty which is again just
actually having gunfights but that being
said you know any time the camera pulls
out and I see the larger map we're
playing in I just want these maps to be
bigger and like just about food player
in you just take a chance just like I
had a couple more players and make your
maps a little bigger because they're
small you especially in team deathmatch
you're always contending with a spawn
flip which always means there's somebody
shooting you in the back like if you're
in the middle of the map I guarantee
you're gonna get shot in the back
because somebody's gonna spawn behind
you and if they had slightly larger Maps
they could probably avoid yeah maybe a
halo 5 Guardians will scratch that itch
for you and like it what do you feel
about it yeah I like what it's taking
from advanced warfare in terms of the
movement it definitely feels like a less
pared down version of that and more you
know obviously black ops combined with
titanfall just not doing either to an
extreme I think the specialist being the
major addition is interesting enough to
pull me back in but after you play for
about an hour it still feels like Call
of Duty again the last eight we've
played it's got me hooked I won't lie
and it's so hard to like try and figure
out have those systems are working when
you're playing like the first two days
of an online shooter because like two
weeks down the road it's like a
completely different ball game yeah and
so the fact that there are so few people
playing when we were playing it was kind
of always team deathmatch
rice I was looking forward to trying out
hardcore mode to see how different the
weapon loadouts would work and how
different abilities would work and you
know like I don't know that they're
bringing hardpoint back from advanced
warfare yeah but I'm just interested to
see how those specialist abilities will
not only affect how I'm building classes
but how I'll build different classes for
different game modes as well cool Mike
and I are thanks so much for coming on
yeah talking to us all the bad they call
of duty black ops 3 is that later this
year and the beta is running up until
sunday and also if you're watching right
now you can win yourself a key to the
beta give them away hopefully on there
it is a judge so certain yet for a
chance to win go to tinyurl com for it /
card giveaway really no one had cod
giveaway pun that's amazing idiots cod
giveaway go there right now you can win
a beta code for the sony playstation
gaming system for and this is only for
us people because we hate Europe no time
for Asia and I don't think anyone's
watching in Africa so no it's cuz the
keys are American sorry and North
American North American r us only us
only take that kind of that and so if
you want in on that go to tonnnyal calm
for its star card giveaway and do
whatever things they ask the you to do
on the page and then you can win how
about that cool gonna go play some call
duty boys I probably will
you